[Musique]
je suis donc pierre raynaud président
fondateur du comité valentin hauy de la
réunion et l'océan indien aux indiens
qui est l'antenne régionale de
l'association valentin haüy la plus
ancienne et la plus grosse association
au service des personnes aveugles et
malvoyantes la déficience visuelle la
mal voyance ou la cécité isole les
personnes et notre volonté nous c'est de
rompre cet isolement
à travers des actions de loisirs de
détente comme des balades des randonnées
des activités touristiques et de détente
mais aussi toute une action au niveau de
la lecture de la promotion de la lecture
audio pour les publics empêchés d
actions de représentation et de défense
des intérêts des personnes aveugles et
malvoyantes au sein de différentes
instances collectives
curieux et volontaire curieux parce que
j'aime beaucoup apprendre
j'aime rencontrer du monde j'aime
découvrir de nouvelles choses et
volontaire parce que je pense être assez
volontaire justement pour pour monter
des projets pour aller vers l'autre et
aller vers de nouvelles aventures de
nouveaux projets que ce soit des projets
personnels associatifs ou professionnels
moi personnellement tank aveugle j'ai
connu l'avant et l'après numérique et le
numérique m'a fait faire un bond de
géant dans en termes de gain en
autonomie m'a ouvert des portes
extraordinaire je suis responsable d'un
espace elle s est si basse du conseil
départemental à saint pierre qui a en
charge de l'inclusion numérique de
public éloigné du numérique que sont les
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes et
parallèlement j'ai toujours travaillé
dans l'accessibilité numérique c'est à
dire comment faire en sorte que le
numérique soit accessible à tous mon
rêve pour l'avenir c'est un monde
accessible c'est un monde où où je
puisse de plus en plus accéder à des
services quels qu'ils soient que ce soit
des services numériques ou autres une
accessibilité universelle
voilà mon rêve
[Musique]